[Music]
a lot of stuff moving around in the
economy
yes a lot of inflation and recession
worries gas prices are enough to give
you a freaking heart attack
god i filled up my raptor and i just
about just laid down in the middle of
the gas station parking lot and held my
heart for a minute
oh man i mean because you fill up a
prius it's one thing but when you fill
up a raptor yeah it's another man i'm
just saying i can only imagine wow
i bought houses cheaper than that back
in the day but oh my gosh
it's it's a thing and you go to the
grocery store and you you know you put
your buggy's half full
of what it was and it's just as much
money it's almost like shopping at whole
foods every day that's you know i mean
it's like really it's crazy and you used
to call it whole paycheck right but the
uh uh
you know it's it's wild out there the
interest rates have gone way up on
housing
um house prices of course have gone way
up in 20 and in 21 they're up a little
this year
um
and everybody's you know worrying about
a real estate crash now and and and
labor cost
to hire someone to get a job
you know i'm seeing a lot of comments
and stuff flowing through in our place
right now is like how do i how do i i
can't even make it i mean i can't
inflation has just destroyed what was
left of my little budget
um but in my mind when i hear that
there's always two sides to each
budgeting equation the in goes income
side and the outgo side i also know that
they're no longer paying people ten
dollars an hour to put the bread on the
shelves they're not paying them 20 to 30
an hour to put the bread on which is why
the cost of bread went up by the way
it wasn't wheat
and it wasn't a shortage it's the cost
of labor oh and the diesel fuel in the
truck to deliver the bread oh yeah
that's built into that
so that's why your loaf of bread went up
that's why sharon bought some bologna
the other day and man that was a lot of
money what that's just it's real food
but sharon bought bologna oh for me yes
homegrown tomato big red onion big old
piece of white bread and
that's better than filet mignon man
don't you know anything i i just i know
you have a very pride a little bit it's
a redneck it's a redneck
man frying the bologna you cried a
little bit you put it on there oh man
that's about it you could take the boy
out of the side tracked here but anyway
the point being that if your budget is
stressed ken
and your your salary is fixed
it might be time to look that's correct
because you might be able to make a
whole lot more money somewhere else but
be careful because you could jump over
into one of these companies that have
lost their minds and are doing all kinds
of crazy butt stuff and then you get
stuck in the middle of the crazy butt
stuff oh yeah we're seeing a lot of that
now the facts are just give you two
different stories
when you change jobs we've seen over the
last year and a half you're looking at
about a 14
on average pay bump well i would cover
your inflation that's pretty nice
especially if you adjust your budget you
know i also saw a story recently on the
news about this couple that's uh they're
extreme frugal savers and budgeters
probably our kind of people and they're
like we're not even feeling the
inflation i know that when we do these
debt-free screams over the last six
months
inflation doesn't come up at all
so there is a way to do it the way that
we teach it works but let's give you
some good news about the economy just
reported on my show today that uh olive
garden
they beat their projections
uh and what have they done they've kept
their prices low and turns out families
like a lot of free bread sticks and um
you know bottomless salad
but
the point is my weight in both of those
right but here's a story that you're not
hearing in the media
when a restaurant like that decides you
know what we're going to keep our costs
where they are it's costing us a little
bit more but they got more people coming
in because they're offering things so
you hear this bad news about inflation
and the economy we also saw today
reported today that uh for the first
time in seven months home sales spiked
in may so
this doomsday stuff we need to get over
it well it it's those are good
indications anxiety and the fear
around filling up your car and almost
passing out is real absolutely right the
anxiety and the fear over you know half
the stuff in the grocery basket and it's
just as expensive as real
however what's just as real is there's
almost an across-the-board increase in
wages and if you haven't received that
then you should talk to your employer
because he's getting ready to have to
replace you that's right and there's
opportunity like we've never seen before
we still see a level what we are paying
for a position at ramsey has changed
dramatically in 12 months based on the
marketplace that's correct in order to
get someone to do x or y or z
it is different than it was 12 months
ago and that difference is at least 14
percent that's correct that's the
average yeah so folks that's the average
of people that change jobs so we'll take
those calls today because dave's right
we don't want to chase just a paycheck
because that'll wear off if you're in a
crappy culture with gossip people you
leave a good company and you go into a
bunch of crap and they're doing the
the woke agenda and then and you hate
that stuff and you all of a sudden
you're going to be spending all your
money on your time on that instead of
actually helping people doing work
correct so um
we're quite the opposite around here at
ramsey we're kind of boring old
dinosaurs and um and kind of proud of
that by the way but the uh um
anyway the uh yeah so i mean you you
make sure you're going to a company that
aligns with your values maybe you want
to do all the woke stuff then go you
need to make sure they're doing all that
stuff
um a lot of them are doing you know
they're going overboard with it because
they're just virtue signaling that's
correct and so if you leave a good
company like i mean we had a young man
that left here a while back and he
texted this weekend and he's like oh god
this place is a disaster that i went to
and he got he got more money than we
were paying him so he got a raise but he
went into a miss you know and so be
careful that you're not doing that or be
careful you're not taking a job that you
hate or be careful that you're not
thinking something's you know what it
was i had a
another guy a friend of mine left his
position because he was gonna work 20
hours a week from home for more money
yeah now he's working 80 hours a week
yeah from home well there's a lot more
money yeah it's a mirage a lot of people
well here's here's what's unique about
ramsey solutions and we're always hiring
so you know you need to be checking out
ramsey ramseysolutions.com but we know
from research i spoke about this at our
entre leadership summit here are three
human needs that we all want fulfilled
at work number one we want to see
meaning and purpose in our work we have
a crusade mentality because we're giving
people hope and real practical steps for
life transformation at this company
number two we want to be recognized for
our unique contribution i can't tell you
the stories of people that are
executives here in this company who
started out as administrative assistants
and because we recognize people's hard
work we recognize their talent we give
them an opportunity to get promoted they
do here
i'm sitting on my operating board two of
them and then the third thing that we
need is we want a relationship with our
leader i cannot tell you how much this
company cares for its people it's a real
relationship with the people that you
report to if you don't have that find it
somewhere yeah find it somewhere and
make sure if you're going for more money
that you get that too or else the money
will be you'll be hating your life all
for a few bucks that's right but you can
help with inflation by either an upward
a raise at your current place
or a uh a move to somewhere else well i
work for the state well maybe it's time
to move somewhere else they're probably
not going to give you a 12 inflationary
raise this year and you probably can get
it somewhere else this is the ramsey
show